in this video you're gonna learn how to
work with linear programming problems so
let's dive in the first thing you want
to know is how to work with the
constraints the feasible region and your
objective function what you're trying to
minimize or maximize so just a bird's
eye view what you're trying to do is
you're trying to graph these linear
inequalities and what you get is an
overlapping region that satisfies all
those constraints or those inequalities
and this red region here I'm just
showing you an example this would
represent what's called our feasible
region and if you pick any point in that
region it satisfies the constraints but
what's interesting is that at the
vertices at these points on this polygon
that's formed here will give you either
a maximum value or a minimum value
depending on what you're trying to find
so let's go ahead and do a basic example
first where we're trying to minimize and
then we're gonna do a word problem where
we're gonna try to maximize okay so for
number one our objective function is
this Z equals 2x plus 3y and what we
want to do is we want to minimize Z we
want to find the smallest value for Z
now that constraints this is what these
are our restrictions or these are our
inequalities we want to graph to get our
feasible region so X is greater than
equal to 0 that's a vertical line and
greater than we're gonna be shading to
the right Y is greater than or equal to
0 y equals lines are horizontal lines
and that's gonna be greater than that's
gonna be above so what that does is that
puts us in the first quadrant we've got
two more we've got 3x plus 6 y is
greater than equal to 24 what I'm going
to do for this one is I'm just going to
make a table and find the x and y
intercepts so if X is 0 3 times 0 is 0
so I'm just going to cover that up
divide both sides by 6 so you can see
that Y is going to equal 4 and then if I
set Y to 0 0 times 6 is 0 and if I
divide by 3 to both sides X is going to
equal 8 so that's just a quick way this
is called the intercept method of
graphing inequality so we've got 0 4 1 2
3 4 that's going to put us right here
and 8 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 0 and I'm just
going to draw a solid line because it's
equal to
and then when you graph using the X and
y intercepts like this you want to pick
a point on either side of this line and
test it to see if it makes it true so
for example if I put zero zero in that's
the origin this test point here is zero
greater than equal to 24 well no so that
means we wouldn't want to shade on this
side of the line we want to shade on
this side of the line so let me go ahead
and just draw some lines just so we know
we're on this side okay for the second
inequality Y is greater than or equal to
negative 3 X plus 9 so we see that the
y-intercept is 9 so that's going to be 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 the slope is negative 3
which is like negative 3 over 1 so we're
going to go down 3 or 1 down 3 over 1
etc so let me just kind of draw this in
okay something like that and this one Y
is by itself and when y is greater then
that means that we're going to be
shading above the line so what that
means is I'm going to be shading on this
side of the line so let me just draw
some lines just to illustrate some
shading here ok like that now you can
see that we were above the x-axis we
were to the right of the y-axis were
above this line and we're above this
line so what happens here is that where
do all these regions overlap well
they're overlapping right here here here
in like this so basically if I kind of
go back and shade this a little bit
darker here it's gonna put us in this
region here now this is what's referred
to as an unbounded region because you
can see it keeps going like this it
keeps going over to it like that and so
you know continues forever and ever but
what we're gonna do now is we're gonna
pick the points these vertices along
this region here so we're gonna take
this point here which was the point
let's see 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 so 0 9 we're
to take this point here which we're
gonna solve for in a minute and then
we're gonna take this point here which
is 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 comma 0 now how do we
find this point here this is probably
the toughest part of the problem well
remember this is this line
and this is this line and we're trying
to find where the intersects so that's
these two lines here so what we're gonna
do is we're going to treat them like
equations not inequalities now if we're
just going to treat them like lines we
want to find the intersection point and
I think the easiest way to do this one
is to use substitution so if Y is equal
to negative 3x plus 9 let's put that in
place of Y here in this equation so we
get 3x plus 6 times negative 3x plus 9
is equal to 24 so let's go ahead and
solve this distribute that gives us
negative 18x plus 54 bring down the 3x
this comes out to negative 15 X subtract
the 54 that's negative 30 and divide
both sides by negative 15 and X is equal
to 2 now if we take 2 and we put it back
in here you get negative 3 times 2 is
negative 6 plus 9 is 3 so you can see Y
is equal to 3 and that's the coordinates
of this point right here 2 comma 3 so
now what we're gonna do is we're going
to take these vertices put them into our
objective function and see which one
gives us the minimum value the smallest
value so let's go ahead and put 0 in for
X 9 and for y so that's going to be 2
times 0 which is 0 3 times 9 is 27 0
plus 27 is 27 so for this point we get a
value of 27 let's put in 2 & 3 so 2 4 X
2 times 2 is 4 3 times 3 is 9 4 plus 9
is 13 okay at that point and then if we
pick 8 0 2 times 8 is 16 3 times 0 0 16
plus zero is 16 so which one gave us the
minimum value it looks like this one
right here 13 so to minimize you would
want there to be 2 of whatever the X
quantity is 3 whatever whatever the Y
quantity is and that's going to give you
a minimum value of 13 so let's go ahead
and dive into a word problem now where
we're gonna maximize the profit before
we dive into this word problem if you're
new to the channel and we haven't met
yet my name is Mario of Mario's math
tutoring and my goal for this channel is
to make learning math less stressful so
that you can raise your grade pass your
class and go on to pursue your dreams so
I'm a full time math tutor I work with
students every day and what I do is I
try to find
simplest and easiest and most
understandable way to do some of these
problems and I take it and try to
condense it down and put it into these
videos so that you can benefit from from
my tutoring as well so if that's
something you're interested in check out
more videos on my Mario's math tutoring
YouTube channel but let's dive into
number two a company produces two bikes
a mountain bike in a road bike it takes
three hours to assemble a mountain bike
and takes four hours to assemble a road
bike the total time available to
assemble bikes is 60 hours the company
wants to have at least twice as many
mountain bikes as road bikes to sell the
company makes a profit of $200 per road
bike and $100 per mountain bike how many
of each bike should be made to maximize
the profit so that's kind of a lot of
words there and usually what I recommend
when you're doing these story problems
is just kind of read through real
quickly you don't have to get everything
the first time and then usually what you
want to focus on on these optimization
these linear programming problems is is
the last sentence that'll you tell you
the story as far as what you're looking
to to maximize or minimize and it'll
also tell you what your variables are so
let's do that so it says how many of
each bike should be made to maximize the
profit so we know we're trying to
maximize profit and we're trying to
figure out how many rode bikes on how
many mountain bikes so why don't we call
the mountain bikes ax and we're gonna
call the road bikes Y okay so on our
graph here I'm just gonna say X is
mountain bikes and Y over here is going
to be the road bikes okay so now let's
look at what are called the constraints
these are our restrictions or
limitations see how it says it takes
three hours to assemble a mountain bike
and four hours to assemble a road bike
but you only have sixty hours available
so can you work more than 60 hours no it
has to be less than or equal to 60 so
we've got three hours to assemble a
mountain bike we have four hours to
assemble a road bike but the amount of
time spent assembling has to be less
than or equal to 60 hours now notice
like see if you assembled like four
mountain bikes well four times three
hours per mountain bike that's 12 hours
assembling mountain bikes right or if
you did five road bikes five times four
hours to assemble one road bike that's
20 hours spent and you want to make sure
that two
less than or equal to 60 now what other
constraints are there well we know that
you can't assemble like a negative
number of bikes right so right off the
bat we know that X has to be greater
than or equal to 0 the number of
mountain bikes and the number of road
bikes also has to be greater than
because 0 so what that does is it puts
us you know in this first quadrant
because X is greater than equal to 0 y
is greater than 0 those are gonna
overlap in the first quadrant but we
also have one more constraint here it
says the company wants to have at least
twice as many mountain bikes as road
bikes to sell right so they want to have
at least twice as many mountain bikes so
the number of mountain bikes X has to be
at least that's greater than or equal to
twice as many road bikes okay so maybe
mountain bikes are more popular right
but what's interesting about this
inequality is seeing we have an X by
itself we could rearrange is to get Y by
itself but we'll do that in a minute the
first thing we want to do though is we
want to look at a couple different ways
to graph these like you see how this
one's kind of like in a standard form
see how the variables are on the Left
numbers on the right usually when it's
in this form I like to use the intercept
method I set X to 0 and I solve for y
and I set Y to 0 and I solve for X you
don't have to do that if you want you
can rearrange the equation and solve for
y and put it into y equals MX plus B
form a lot of students prefer that
method but let's try and do the
intercept method for this inequality so
X is 0 3 times 0 is 0 I'm going to cover
that up since it's nothing divide both
sides by 4 that means that Y is 15 if Y
is 0 4 times 0 is 0 that's nothing cover
that up divide by 3 you can see X is
going to be 20 when y is 0 so let's plot
those points so 0 15 it's right there 20
0 that's going to be right there we're
gonna draw a solid line since this is
equal to right and then what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna do a test point I'm
going to pick the origin 0 0 if I put 0
in for X and Y that makes a 0 is 0 less
than or equal to 60 yes so that means
where this test point is that that's
true so you want to shade on that side
of the
the line and remember we were in the
first quadrant because of these two
constraints for the last one though you
see how this is X is greater than equal
to Y let's get Y by itself so we're
going to divide both sides by two and so
that gives you one-half X is greater
than or equal to Y and I'm gonna flip
this whole inequality so it's actually y
is less than or equal to one-half X so
let's go ahead and graph this one now
the y-intercept is 0 the slope is 1/2 so
I'm going up 1 over 2 now see really I
went up 5 over 10 but because the scale
on the x and y axis is the same you can
think of it it's just going up one unit
over to two steps and then let's repeat
that so up one over two would put you
right about there and this one is also
equal to so it's gonna be a solid line
like this right but Y is less than now
when you have the Y by itself okay on
one side of the inequality if Y is less
than Y controls that up and down right
so less that means we're shading below
this line if you want you can do a test
point you can pick a point over here see
if it makes the inequality true if it's
false you shade the other side of this
true you would shade where that test
point is so that means we're gonna be
shading below this line right now you
can see where are the overlapping or
below this line we're below this line
we're above the x-axis were to the right
of the y-axis it's going to be right in
this region right here it kind of forms
like a triangular region the main thing
that we're interested in are now are the
vertices of that feasible region okay
that polygon that's formed right so we
know this point that's easy 0 0 we know
this point that's easy that's 20 comma 0
how do we find this point that's
probably the toughest part about the
problem right well it looks like this is
the intersection of these two lines y
equals 1/2 X we're just going to treat
like an equation and this one here 3x
plus 4y equals 60 I think the easiest
thing to do is to do a substitution so
if y equals 1/2 X I'm going to put 1/2 X
here so that comes out to 3x plus 4
times 1/2 X because we're putting 1/2 X
and for y equals 60 we're just treating
it like an equation 4 times 1/2 is 2x
Plus 3x that's 5x divided by five you
can see X's coming out to 12 if we put
12 back in here or here it doesn't
matter either one 1/2 times 12 is 6 so
our Y value equals 6 so this point is
really right here at 12 comma 6 now all
we have to do is test which one of these
points is going to give us the maximum
profit because that's what we're trying
to maximize now we didn't write the
formula for the profit equation yet so
let's do that profit equals you make
$100 per mountain-bike so it's a hundred
times X and you make $200 for each
roadbike so that's gonna be plus 200 Y
so we're going to do is we're going to
take each points in this fees I you know
on the vertices of this feasible region
we're gonna plug it into our profit
equation of course if you sell 0
mountain bikes and 0 road bikes 100
times 0 200 times 0 that's a profit of 0
okay if we do this point over here 20
mountain bikes and 0 road bikes that's
gonna be 20 times 100 is 2,000 plus 0 so
this is going to give us a profit of
2,000 and if we do 12 comma 6 if we put
12 in for X and 6 + 4 y that gives us
1200 plus 6 times 200 is also 1200 so
this is giving us a profit here of 2400
and so which one was the greatest since
we were trying to maximize profit well
2400 is larger than 2000 larger than 0
so this is going to maximize our profit
if we make 12 mountain bikes and 6 road
bikes that will satisfy the constraints
or the restrictions but still you know
keep the profit at them at a maximum so
if you want to see another example I did
another video on linear programming
follow me over to that video right there
and I'll show you how to work with that
one